I got a joke I'm working on maybe you
can help me with this no bigger change
than cigarettes and weed when I was a
kid weed was the devil's grass you were
a criminal you were a drug addict and
cigarettes everybody just smoked no
bigger progress than cigarettes and weed
when I was a kid cigarettes were
completely normal everybody smoked when
I was kid cigarettes totally normal
everybody smoked when I was a kid
cigarettes were everybody smoked it was
normal I was kid everybody smoked now
weed like got his [__] together weed
went to [__] med school and [__] yeah
when I was good everybody smoked my mom
my grandmother now smoking's like kind
of shameful and then weed used to be a
drug used to put you in jail now weed
got its medical degree and turn its life
around those two completely traded
places you want to smoke a cigarette now
you got to go out in an alley behind a
dumpster you're like what are you doing
over there you're like uh I'm paying a
hooker I'm not smoking I'll tell you
that right now